oh
et oui ami diego note me voici de retour
pour la fin la fin de ce match fait 2 2
les deux dernières semi rapides et voire
même les huit de départage pour ce
championnat du monde kramnik topaloff
et bien pas d'invité pour cette dernière
ligne droite sur ce championnat
une personne est disponible tout
simplement donc on va l'analyser pour
vous et bien moi tout seul je vais
essayer de me débrouiller comme je peux
voilà la partie numéro 3 entre topaloff
est chronique
parti numéro 3 de céder partagent pour
l'instant kramnik mène déjà une victoire
à zéro d'un cd partage donc comme dans
le match on peut dire que il prend il
prend les devants pendant le match il a
mené tout de suite au début du match il
s'est fait ensuite remonté par topalov
avec cette fameuse partie par forfait
évidemment on en parlera peut-être
encore très longtemps de cette ce
scandale qui a un peu éclaboussé le
championnat du monde est
donc ici voilà pendant que je change de
caméras c'est un effet d'un effet de
régie donc je disais on va on va
maintenant on va maintenant se
concentrer sur cette fin de match avec
avec cette troisième c'est troisième
partie des partages entre kramnik et
topalov crâne menant au score avec une
victoire c'est c'est la dernière
peut-être la dernière chance de topalov
de revenir dans le match puisque il a
les blancs danser les parties
semi-rapides alors on voit tout de suite
cette partie de topalov sa chronique et
on voit que ça ne dévient toujours pas
les joueurs sont concentrés sur leur
ouverture des quatre des cinq c4 c6
comme d'habitude cavalier trois
cavaliers c6 donc on est dans une
défense lave toujours pareil avec cette
structure caractéristiques pour
l'épauler noir de trois fous et 5,2
cramique qu'avait laissé 3 o6 tout ça
est connue quadrillage quatre classiques
c'est comme ça que tout palausse avait
réussi à gagner une partie contre
kramnik on l'avait vu et
c'est aussi avec cette ouverture que
kramnik à essayer de battre topalov dans
la lah 12e
je sais plus oui dans la 12e partie
c'est ça il a joué aussi cette ouverture
ce fameux kookaï h4 qui est là pour
échanger se fout de cases blanches ou g6
fous eux deux les blancs retard de la
prise en justice ils se disent qu'ils
ont le temps cavaler p17 petit rock food
et 6 g iii les blancs retarde encore
toujours cette prise angers 6 sont pas
pressés pour l'instant qui on prend ces
quatre [ __ ] en c4 de topalov calais b
6 2 kramnik il pose la question fou ou
tuba est ce que tu vas en b3 est-ce que
tu reviens à eux deux que tu proposerait
un échange non ce serait une mauvaise
idée puisque le cavalier est venue ici
c'est pour s'échanger évidemment fou et
de petit rock
maintenant évidemment c'est peut-être ça
qu attendait les blancs le fait que
l'europe soit fait afin de prendre en
g600 que la tour ici est une action
contre le roi voilà l'idée de la tente
des blancs donc cavaler projet 6h
pranger 6 maintenant on revient qu'à
tourner plus là une fois que le rock a
été fait donc ça change un peu les
caractéristiques de la position on avait
vu comment topaloff avait réussi à
monter justement une attaque contre le
roi de kramnik dans la deuxième partie
une contre attaque en fin de partie sur
cette colo 9 h
maintenant 13 e 4,2 topalov maintenant
il met ses pions au centre donc c'est
assez classique on décide d'envahir le
centre topalov a fait plusieurs fois
cette cette possibilité qu'il avait
suivi par paref 4 d'ailleurs on va le
voir que ça va être la même idée après
e52 crâne et qui est logique on veut
empêcher les blancs de jouer eux mêmes
cinq et on veut échanger ce pion contre
le pion des 4 donc on veut pas surtout
pas que les blancs jouer 5 ce qui leur
donnerait un avantage significatif des
espaces au centre notamment la casse des
six qui serait faible
on peut imaginer en plus des cinq
classes une tout de suite une
une fourchette alors eu cinq f4 donc
logique de topalov on prend pas le sait
mais on joue f4 on menace maintenant qu'
on prend le simple pion f.fillon
déprendre 5
donc il faut absolument que les
maintenant les noirs échange on avait vu
dans le match que kramnik avait réussi à
trouver une solution pour éviter cette
situation en mettant la vda mambé cissé
en clouant le pion des quatre sur le roi
c'était une partie qu'il avait perdu
d'ailleurs parti qu'ils avaient perdue
je sais plus lequel s'est alors ensuite
qui on prend des quatre dames prendre
des cadres d'amener cette voie là alors
attention puisque là il ya quand même
une fourchette
alors que se passe-t-il si les blancs
jouent le coup eux 5
et bien c'est très simple les noirs avec
le coup fut csn protégé par la dame et
l'adami scier clouer sur le roi donc la
menace de dames 7 c'est de jouer pouces
et 5 souvent le roi il n'y a pas de ya
pas de double prise ici on croit g2 donc
logique on sort le roi de ces fameux
clouage fous ces cinq chroniques
alors on continue par dam des trois
logiques un fond mais même être la dame
quelque part en d3 elle n'empêche pas le
fou ici de sortir ici ou en d2 alors
voilà donc c'est un coup logique tour à
des huit ont gagné le temps de
développement d'une tour sur la dame
dams et 2 case logic pour la dame
rien à dire sur ce coup là dame est bien
placé en c2 elle a un oeil sur le pion à
4 il a maintenant food et 4,2 kramnik
alors avec l'idée qui est très simple
c'est de faire [ __ ] en cavalier et
maintenant le point 4 n'est plus défendu
donc après dun trempions échec tout
simplement proposant même un échange de
dames éventuellement si la dame reprend
le style pardon si le pion reprend après
dans prend ici échec en échangeant plus
les dames en ayant gagné un pion autant
dire que kramnik s'envolerait vers le
titre e 5 pour topalov qui doit
absolument
orthez dans cette partie là les blancs
pour la dernière fois il est mené au
score ils attaquent le cavalier de
kramis qui jouent ils lancent toutes ses
forces dans la bataille
cavalier f des cinq noeuds cramique
logique on vit sur une case où on est
protégé par son autre cavalier tous
trois concurrents lieu de topalov et on
va voir on va voir que ce coût est très
très bien joué pour plus tard on va voir
que topalov a de la suite dans les idées
alors un jouet tour 3 l'avantagent aussi
c'est qu'ils contrôlent une fois de plus
la case 3 avec le fou le cavalier
empêchant notamment des des fourchettes
de cavaliers ici en faisant échec au roi
attaquant la dame qui ont été obligés de
donner le fou topalov veut garder très
certainement sa paire de fou alors
cavalli prend c-32 kramnik l'éliminent 6
lecavalier
évidemment il faut reprendre du poids il
n'y a pas le choix puisque le fou troll
la case fous ces 5
donc là on recule et maintenant topalov
donc vous gardez c'est fou il faut 3
semblait bon mais un coût de
développement possible et changeant ce
fou qui est quand même assez fort mais
métaux pas leur faire garder sa paire de
fou donc qui joue plutôt un coût plus
qui paraît moins ambitieux premier abord
food et 2 to tranquille voilà mais ils
n'échangent pas les fous il veut garder
sa paire de fou tour 17,2 cramique qui
veut certainement doubler les tours pour
menacer la casse des deux tours 1 et
maintenant
topalov lui maintenant ramène la
dernière pièce qui jouait pas sur la
case 1
il veut garder sans doute un oeil sur le
point 5 et topalov clairement il a ici
une majorité de pions face à une
minorité en face une minorité de pions
noirs
topalov veut créer veut créer une
attaque de maths très certainement sur
l'europe de kramnik tous rêvent des 8,2
kramnik faisant ici pression sur la
colonne des attaquants tout simplement
la menace évidemment si tu reprends fut
donc il faut choisir de défendre ce fou
soit on peut bouger fou soit on peut
trouver une autre solution que
trouve-t-on pas l'ofs très élégante fou
détroit le fou ici est protégé par la
tour et par la dame et ils risquent pas
grand chose se fout puisque la dame
noire ne peut pas se rajouter à la
puissance des tours adverses puisque
tout simplement déjà il ya un pion qui
empêche et que derrière n'a plus de gaz
tout simplement aller tous reprennent
toutes les cases donc on peut pas
augmenter la pression sur se fout des
trois donc qui est très bien placé
finalement détroit et qui bloque la tacc
détour sur le fou des deux donc très
joliment jouer de topalov puisque ce fou
quand même beaucoup plus actif quand
l'un d'eux et on voit que tout de suite
il a une action potentiel sur le roi
déjà une possibilité pour les blancs
vous remarquerez c'est de menacer le cou
aux six imaginons un coup un peu c'est
pas un peu idiot des noirs le kw à 6 par
exemple et même peut-être le coup aussi
c'est possible tout de suite voilà parce
que sur pions prend 2,6 qui paraît
obligatoire puisque on attaque à la fois
la tour et le pion imaginons puis on
prend 2,6 et bien tout simplement
prendre et le fou le pion g6 sur
l'entraîneur de garder la bêtise puisque
le fou des deux camps prise donc c'est
pas possible non alors c'est pas c'est
pas la menace directe excusez moi c'est
pas la menace directe
comme quoi on peut dire des bêtises
n'est ce pas c'est pas mal d'erreurs
mais en tout cas c'est dans l'air on
peut aussi recyclé sous phocéen et après
ce sera une possibilité voilà donc c'est
pas il se le dise est une est une erreur
alors dames 6 de la part des noirs alors
ce coup permet de bloquer déjà ce pion
ce plan b
un petit oeil sur la case à 2 même si
l'ombre pas trop comment on pourrait
attaquer plus cette case mais surtout ça
bloque le pion et ça mais la dame aussi
surface blanche permettant
éventuellement aussi à ce fou de revenir
en défense ans et suit une autre
possibilité en tout cas c'est une dame
qui bloque
mais combien de temps pourra t elle
bloquée puisque regardez maintenant que
les possibilités de topalov c'est de
jouer f5
alors ça contrôle aussi la case rica
donc ça retarde le coup g3 g4 suivi de
f5
voilà donc plutôt qu'aller très bien
placé puisque ici elle est
complémentaire avec le fou
dams aux cases blanches frousse aux
cases noires ici topalov donc jouent ce
fameux coup phocéen voilà ça y est la
recycler son fou donc maintenant les
possibilités que l'on disait tout à
l'heure si la dame partait de beauxis
deviennent possibles f5 de kramnik donc
là on comprend
voilà kramnik veut essayer d'empêcher
totalement le coup les possibilités de
g4 de f5 et ses bras il essaie de
bloquer le problème étant que pour les
blancs on peut pas prendre en passant ce
qui est en général la réponse appropriée
prise en passant puisque si on prend en
passant voilà donc le pion a disparu il
avait bougé de deux cases on l'a pris en
passant maintenant parce que la tour
serait emprise voilà donc kramnik
profite du fait qu'après ici le fou
contrôler la tour après dames 6 phocéen
le fou ne protège plus cette tour c'est
le bon moment pour jouer 5 voilà ils
bloquent mais on voit quand même connu
le problème c'est que ça donne un gros
gros pions passé centrale au blanc on
peut dire lac déjà que les blancs ont un
avantage est en tout cas peuvent
clairement joué pour le gain ce que
cherchait à faire topalov dans me2 alors
dame eux deux
le coup est intéressant puisque il
contrôle la casse et 4 une fois de plus
alors par exemple une menace possible ce
serait de jouer à 4 à 5 60 cavaliers et
à prix fous ces quatre avec un flash de
la dame voilà tout simplement une
possibilité et c'est un coup aussi qui
permet d'envisager de contrôle et
peut-être aussi la cage h5 plus tard
pour jouer des ruptures avec h4 et h5
voilà une possibilité aussi donc là on
veut on vise clairement le roi ça fait
aucun doute
quatre pions contre 3 maintenant un pion
passé père de fou on peut dire que la
position des blancs est très très forte
et que topalov a réussi à prendre un
gros avantage dans ce troisième semi
rapide tour f 8 e par droit et fuite
deux cramique donc la logique kramnik
justement sort de ce genre de
possibilités de clouage du roi voilà
tout simplement c'est quand même
important d'éviter des échecs éventuel
ça peut c'est un profil à petit tour d
un ici de topalov qui surprotègent sont
fous des trois l'avantagent c'est qu'ils
libèrent un peu cette tour f3 de la
défense du fou puisque maintenant cet
ol-là supplée donc l' avantage de la
surprotection qui est un thème cher à
ninon beach le père de la théorie
moderne c'est que quand toutes les
pièces protège la même case eh bien
elles sont d'autant plus libérée
cette tour maintenant est libre de
bouger puisque
cette tour cette dame et sept tours
c'est deuxième tour sans libre de bouger
parce que tout le monde participe à la
défense du fou détroit qui est
surprotégé sur les protéger une fois de
plus dams est pour kramnik et maintenant
c'est l'heure h 4 c'est ce que je vous
disais la demande eu un petit oeil sur h
5 h 4 h 5 est dans l'air du temps
d'autant plus que le pion f5 aussi va
s'avérer faible en k 2 h 5
la perte de ce projet 6 et le pion au f5
peut s'avérer faible attention quand
même à cette batterie de tours qui
attaqueraient la tour d un tour des
scènes de chroniques ou d'attentes
typiquement cours d'attentes ou
d'attentes chronique et c'est de dire
aux blancs maintenant ok je suis pris
j'ai un peu la pression sur moi mais je
vois pas comment tu vas passer donc je
cours beaucoup d'attentes à toi de
démontrer que tu peux trouver des
solutions dans ces deux de topalov ça
c'est des remplacements de pièces et la
petite combinaison déjà deux chroniques
petite tentative de combines car les c4
ils cherchent à pêcher en eau trouble
chronique ici le cavalier est en prise
du fou mais évidemment cas de fou prend
cavaliers on remarque que le roi n'est
plus là il a plus de cloyne très
important on peut prendre la torah nerfs
donc voilà l'idée de kramnik tout
simplement ce cavalier n'est pas en
prise grâce au fait que ce roi a joué un
coup prophylactique tourache un très
joliment jouer au topalov profité du
fait que le fou est déjà très bien
protégé par la dame et à tours pour
mettre la tour sur la colonne h et jouer
h5
si on prend 1,6 ou en tout cas libérés à
tours pour l'attack vers le roi est nu
cavaliers à 3,2 cramique attaque
la dame et propose au food de s'échanger
contre le cavaly ce qui serait une bonne
affaire
ce que ce fou et quand même avec le fond
blanc partie prenante de la paire de fou
qui typiquement dans cette position où
tout est ouvert où les ruptures h 5
voire même g4 plus tard vont permettre
d'exprimer à plein la puissance des fous
on a vraiment envie de
deux des changéens des fous donc de
proposer un échange de fou c'est
toujours positif pour les noirs dames 2
donc évidemment topalov refuse d'échangé
seront ils préfèrent sortir la dame de
la taille du cavalier d'amd cette
attention 1 2 3 ici contre 1 2 donc il
faut faire quelque chose
il revient topaloff il revient en
défense et la b52 kramnik qui essaie
maintenant de créer du contrôle jeu du
côté d'amélie la raison kramnik
puisqu'il a trois pions contre 2 il peut
chercher son salut par une contre
attaque du côté dames et ensuite espérer
des échanges de pièces surtout de la
paire de fou un moment donné et essayer
de créer des contrôles chance mais la
taupe allofs lance l'attaqué là c'est là
qu'on voit que topaloff est quand même
un jour en attaque extraordinaire il a
ensuite attaqué au bon moment il a senti
que la position était mieux on est quand
même en semi rapide il faut avoir une
intuition géniale parce que c'est pas le
calcul qui permet de tout vérifier en
semi rapide donc g4 pour l'aca y ait
rupture il veut évidemment prendre avec
cinq voire même joué h5 prenant justice
prendre f5 donc il faut absolument
réagir avec les noirs et on voit bien
que si les noirs prennent ici ils vont
avoir des pions triplé ce qui est une
horreur
puisqu'en général on arrive très
facilement à gombe et tous les pions
triplé qui peuvent pas se défendre et
chronique est quand même obligé de
prendre g4 ce qu'il fait et maintenant
tour j'ai trois et on voit très
simplement peu la tour bat tôt ou tard
prendre g4 que le fou va aider à prendre
g6 et que donc on aura gagné un pion et
qu'ici on a deux pions qui sont énormes
dans le pion à eux passés donc l'attaqué
paraît totalement insurmontable les
noirs sont déjà probablement
complètement perdu dans cette position
roy e72 cramique en plus c'est très
difficile à défendre il faut prouver les
seuls coûts et la taupe allofs combine
en plus il est dans son élément topalov
la f5 il a trouvé quelque chose en fait
en jouant f5 topalov c'est pas tellement
la rupture angers 6 qui cherche à faire
c'est tout simplement de libérer son fou
c'est un sur la 4g cinq échecs avait
derrière la tour voire même plus
on va le voir tout de suite j'apprends
f5 quelle combinaison topalov quasiment
obligé et que peut faire cramer a pas
reprendre f5 pour ici sacrifice est pas
bon évidemment on reprendrait de la tour
et on échangerait avec gain évident la
menace des noix des blancs en plus donc
à l'éclair c'est fou j'ai cinq échecs
que faire contre cette menace imaginons
que les blancs empêche les chèques par
par exemple le roi 1,8 ce qui semblerait
très passif et bien tout simplement on
pourrait par exemple jouer le bon 6
protéger déjà par le pion f5 attaquant
la dame où va la dame par exemple sur la
case des six pour garder la puissance
des pièces et bien tout simplement le
ku'damm 3 et 4 voilà le fou toujours
bien protégés et hayatou qui saute tous
ses pions dans sauter avec le roi tout
nu avec deux fous qui vont arriver
pardon se font sur les cases noires se
fout ici sur les cases blanches
c'est horrible donc f 5 pions prend 1,5
et la foulée cinq échecs classique voilà
il ya déjà une petite fille dont on peut
prendre la qualité mais il veut plus
topalov après 3,8
il joue le coup qui est normal qui est
logique dans cette position de 6
pourquoi parce que le fou le pion
maintenant attaque la dame protège afin
attaque tout protégé attaque les cases
blanches ou côté droit et les cases
noires sont attaqués par le fou donc
c'est complémentaire et la taille va
être totalement insurmontable dans le dé
6,2 kramnik et maintenant tout
simplement grand copain l'homme ne prend
même pas la qualité
il veut plus et il a raison de vouloir
plus la position est complètement foutue
foot pro f 5 super beaucoup de topalov
fou prend f5 l'attaqué irrésistible on
voit que c'est tout
ne peut pas être pris par la tour parce
que la dame serait emprise mais là tout
est en prise c'est ce que fait kramnik
il prend la tour et c'est la côte opale
of a tout vu puisqu'après fou j'ai six
échecs roi et fuite
c'est le coût final de la combinaison de
topalov qui gagne tout on va voir que
kramnik va résister encore un peu c'est
eux cet échec on est on boit ici
fourchette avec la tour avec un fou ici
qui protège tous et qui protégerait la
future dame ici ce qui laisse pas le
choix à gravelines qui continue à jouer
mais il est déjà complètement perdu il
prend tout simplement le pion avec la
dame en plus on est en partie rapide
comment défendre une position dont père
la dame en partie rapide contre quelle
quelle compensation est bien juste une
tour une tour une pièce mineurs avec
toujours un roi qui est saoul attaque on
va voir que c'est pas possible de
défendre sous prendre cet échec fou
prend 1,7 et la très jolie coup
terminale je dirais topalov de la
commune pour sa combinaison free des
trois superbes le four revient sur sa
case de départ
protégé par la tour et par la dalle et
il coupe la liaison entre les tours ce
qui fait que cette tour des uns est
attaqué et qu'elle n'a pas de case
vraiment voilà donc en fait ils
désynchronise la la liaison des tours ce
qui leur enlève toute toute force donc
c'est encore plus dur pour les normes
défendre tour à 1,2 cramique attaquant
un petit peu plus on a de lui on voit
que c'est vraiment la défense vraiment
vraiment difficile d'un bep 2 topalov
qui maintenant commence à s'amuser un
peu attaque la tour le cavalier pas
attaquer puisque le fou protège mais là
tout est attaquée tour d un la topalov
revient il à gagner un peu de temps dans
me2 tour à 1 est maintenant dans le
projet 4 tranquille maintenant batterie
menace d'un projet cet échec
tu auras deux échecs 3h trois voies que
le roi ici est très très en sécurité
aucun problème il est sûr qu'à ce
blanche alors que fou sur 15 membres ce
cavalier complètement ans je sais il ya
que cette tour qui est un peu active
celle ci est coupé du camp adverse par
le fou donc comment
tours est fou peuvent résister à une
batterie d'attac dam tour fou contre le
roi tout seul on va voir que ça va être
très difficile
fou et 6 d'annecy cela il prend tout les
cas ce faible taux palosse tour d2 ici
tentant de récupérer la liaison des
tours ce qui est possible mais après fou
g6 qui menacent de 9,7 mat
il faut défendre la case la case fcl
tour de 17
maintenant tous rêvent 3 voilà tout
simplement très bien joué de la part de
notre ami topalov qui attaquent le fou
et 6 menace au plus tard de jouer tout
reprend fou et ensuite d'en prendre
pions échec et on voit que ce petit pion
à jouer un petit rôle puisque après bay
4-2 kramix et le coup h5
voilà qui termine la partie abandons 2
kramnik qu aurait pu faire kramnik
tenter éventuellement de ramener ce
cavalier par exemple par cavalier b5 et
bien non ça marcherait pas à cause du
coup tout simplement h5 qui menacent
quoi h7 et h 8 dames
donc que faire contre ce coup essayer de
ramener encore le cavalier n'y a pas
d'autres coups disponibles et bien tout
simplement à cette voie là acheter ces
dames au prochain coup et si si
évidemment si on prend ce pion mais tout
simplement il ya un très rapide on va le
voir tout reprend des six échecs le seul
coup c'est roger cette tour eiffe cet
échec
alors si on prend la tour ces dames
prend échec 3 h 8 suivi de damas est mat
donc le seul con qui reste ce serait 3 h
8 et maintenant damev six échecs ont
ragé huit dames g7 matt dernière défense
à voir mais elle est vraiment simple
suroît g8
on voit que la dame fort et un échec par
découverte donc tout simplement on peut
jouer tout reprend tour avec échec au
roi c'est horrible y'a plus rien et
c'est ma tante de coûts même en un coup
voilà
c'est matt au prochain coup superbe
partie de topalov donc qui égalise qui
égalise en aidant la troisième on est
dans la troisième partie semi rapide du
match et il ya topalov arrive à égaliser
la partie il reste une partie
il reste une partie semi rapide suite à
quoi on devra décider d'un titre de
champion du monde en partie blitz ce qui
serait une première
les premières mondiales alors est-ce
qu'on va arriver jusque là
eh bien on va voir tout de suite puisque
dans cette émission spéciale championnat
du monde
on va voir maintenant la dernière partie
de ce match entre kramnik et topalov
encore encore une slave encore une slam
chronique qui viennent se faire
rejoindre au score donc l'égalité
parfaite montre les deux hommes
c'est la dernière partie ou chronique
avec les blancs c'était déjà le cas dans
le match 2 parties longues d'un beauf
partie kramnik à l'eiblen dans cette
danse est parti dans cette partie semi
rapide donc ces 20 à 25 minutes par
joueur c'est pour ça que on peut pas se
permettre d'analyser longuement les
coups il se joue quand même avec des
calculs limité par les joueurs
donc il vaut mieux les commenter dans
l'esprit dans l'esprit des parties
rapides
donc on va voir tout de suite cette
partie où kravica les blancs les deux
joueurs quand même se renvoient les
coûts dans ce match c'est coup pour coup
à chaque fois on va voir comment se
déroule sept dernières parties
semi-rapides d4 d5 à noter que le
vainqueur de cette partie serait
champion du monde
c'est la première fois qu'un championnat
du monde se décide en partie rapide si
on excepte le match car profanant de
1998 ou karpov l'avait emporté dans
l'est
dans les parties rapides face à un angle
mais ce n'était pas un match long
c'était un match croit en six parties
qui qui était donc un peu spécial et qui
n'était pas le titre de champion du
monde classique alors que là on a droit
donc au titre de champion du monde
unifié
on fait des synergies qu'est ce qui se
passe en île se passe rien donc je
continue des cadres des 5 c 4
ces six classiques toujours une défense
la kabylie f3 kalyev six cavaliers c3e 6
donc semi slave de topalov qui varie lui
aussi de 3,2 kramnik cavale et b17 food
et 3 donc c'est l'heure toujours très
souvent quand le fou à jouer en d3 pour
prendre ces quatre de façon à profiter
que le fouet joué deux fois et ne pas
prendre ces 4 alors que le foot encore
f1 permettent de gagner 1,1 tant qu' on
prend ces quatre fous prend ses cadres
b5 logique on veut jouer faux bessède
très certainement suite à six et la
libération classique par ces cinq fois
deux foulées cette petit rock fouet 7e 4
2 cramique décidément qui joue
extrêmement agressif dans ses parties
rapides
on notera que cramique beaucoup plus
agressif dans ses parties rapides qu'eux
il ne l'a été dans les parties longues
c'est à dire que kramnik est un est un
très grand joueur de semi rapides on
peut dire même qu'il acquit la demie de
bien meilleurs résultats que messelyn
topalov en partie rapide il a gagné il a
gagné un grand tournoi comme
létourneau ambert monaco où ce genre de
ce genre de l'affrontement donc il est
très très fort en partie rapide et
semble-t-il à un style beaucoup plus
agressif donc en partie rapide qu'en
partie quand il prend plus de risques
parce que sans doute bon mais il fait il
fait un peu plus confiance à son
intuition et vous fait que le manque de
temps empêche l'adversaire de trouver
les meilleurs la meilleure variante
alors des quatre classiques on va
attaquer le cavalier l'idée c'est que si
lecavalier mouge évidemment le pire de 4
est en prison il n'y a pas le choix dans
cette variante il faut contre-attaqué
avec 5 donc si tu prends mon cavalier je
prends ton cavaliers c'est ce que font
les noirs qui comprend que la vallier et
bien prendre pied en faisant cavalier
attaquant le fou donc il faut que les
noirs répondent par foot pro f 6 et
maintenant puis on prend ces trois
égalités matériel on peut dire que la
position est toujours standards
classiques et théoriques et là tout de
suite topalov joue le coup ces cinq
normales coup libérateur qu'il faut
jouer assez vite assez tôt ces cinq
protégé par le cavalier
17 libère la puissance du fou bessette
et en plus élimine ce pion isolé face à
un pion central donc c'est toujours la
bonne solution kramnik choisi sans doute
le meilleur coup ou un des meilleurs
coups en tout cas de prendre ces simples
lui-même tout simplement
à noter que ceux-ci topalov répondait
par fou princes et rois tout simplement
jouer tourbe et un attaquant le fou par
exemple ici fou et 4 ont continué à
attaquer le fou en c3 et après fou et 6
et bien tout simplement le pion ces cinq
étaient attaqués par le cavalier on
pourrait jouer le coup fourré 5 qui
cloue le cavalier aidé par la dame et on
voit que ce pion c5 et tranquille il
sera même soutenu par le fou avec un
gros pions passé comme ça on peut dire
que les blancs même aurait un avantage
puis on pensait cinq cavaliers procès
cinq maintenant classique foulée cinq
échecs on retrouve un thème qu'avait
utilisé cramique dans une de ces parties
précédentes avec un fou des cinq cas
c'est assez tôt avant que le roi n'est
rockets dans la slave roi et fuite
échange de dames de krainik donc qui
aime bien jouer les positions où il a un
léger avantage durable c'est le sait le
style de kramnik de jouer ce genre de
solution donc il n'a pas peur de changer
les dames c'est le joueur qui va
préférer jouer sur les petits davantage
les petites un microscopique plutôt que
de jouer sur sur les grandes attaques
c'est le style de kramnik très très
solide et peut-être le style justement
qui déplaît le plus aux attaquants
c'était pour ça que kramnik a réussi à
battre notamment donc le meilleur
attaquant de l'histoire peut-être garry
kasparov
garry kasparov lui-même à l'an 2000 à
londres elle m'a d'ailleurs que vous
pouvez retrouver sur sur diagonale
toutes les parties analysé soi-même en
direct alors s'est départi donc il faut
vouloir regarder les parties non
l'intégralité ou des résumés des résumés
dans diagonale actualité de ce
championnat du monde entre cramique et
kasparov ou diagonales étaient présents
en direct de londres avec donc des
images des joueurs alors tout reprendre
et 8 et la fois 3 alors fois trois
logiques on cloue le cavalier sur le roi
donc ce qui oblige et noir soit joué le
coup pour ces huit ou fawcett topalov
josé choisi le coutour s'est vite on
peut dire que là la position est sans
doute équilibré alors par il ya
plusieurs facteurs à noter alors d'abord
le roi de topalov n'a pas réussi à roque
est donc un petit retard de
développement et un petit problème avec
cette tour est ce que le roi peut venir
au centre ça paraît délicat
en échange de quoi quand même les blancs
ont un problème avec ce pion à ses pions
quand même une faiblesse potentielle
il est d'ailleurs sous la visée sous la
visée du fou et demi et c'est pourquoi
crâne il joue le coup qu'à valider
quatre ici blocs lent à la fois le four
amenant le cavaly sur une case centrale
à noter que le couffo prend cavaliers
serait pas possible puisque après pions
prend fou évidemment le cavalier cloud
et sera pris au prochain coup par le
purin ou par le fou sachant qu'il ya le
roi derrière ça serait pas possible donc
avec des quatre logique fouet cette donc
on des clous le cavalier torre 21 à 6 de
topalov pose la question aux fous fous
f12 krainik et maintenant voilà l'idée
de topalov il a une fois que ce fou
maintenant à bouger il peut jouer le
coup cavaliers à 4 le cavalier qui ne
pouvaient pas venir sur la case à quatre
temps que le fouetter en v5 faisant
pression sur ce fameux qui ont faible et
proposant au passage un échange de deux
fous donc là kramnik répond avec
sang-froid tour à b1 alors ça c'est un
coup vraiment vraiment de grosses en
froid puisque sa contre attaque le fou
17 mai mais d'un autre côté il ya le
pion c3 qui est en prise du cavalier et
qui proposerait une fourchette
alors que se passe-t-il si topalov joue
cavalier prend pioncer 3 et bien tout
simplement jouer d'abord fou prend 1,7
pour moi prendre 7 et maintenant pour
tomber cet échec et ensuite on enlèvera
tranquillement la tour en ayant gagné
ici de pièces contre une donc une pièce
entière donc voilà l'idée de
traduit alors si les noirs jouent
eux-mêmes le coup fou prend fou
évidemment on prend alors le foot
bessette est maintenant en cas de
cavaliers princes et rois
et bien tout simplement on pourrait
jouer le coutour détroit pour détroit
qui qui pose qui pose le problème déjà
de ces deux pièces attaqué par la tour
même si évidemment la tour s'est vite
protège le cavalier déjà dans un premier
temps et aussi surtout menace de venir
en f3 f3 attaquant kiev 7 avec les deux
pièces ici sachant que lecavalier
pourrait prendre six le roi étant cloué
par là pour donc voilà voilà l'idée de
2,2 cramique tout simplement c'est de
monter une attaque contre le roi donc ça
paraît très dangereux très dangereux de
jouer de jouer ces deux variantes
donc après tour à b1 topalov du coup
joue le couffo et quatre mois donc il
tombe pas dans le piège
il vous faut quatre attaquants là pour
la tourbe et maintenant cramique joue le
coup pour b3 donc protégeant alors
sortant déjà de l'attak du fou
protégeant le fou à trois ans ici
emprise du fawcett
il veut pas évidemment prendre lui-même
en cette chronique puisque le roi amon
torre en 7
il serait plus en attaque sur case noire
puisque les fours disparu et la tourache
8 sortirait très vite il vaut mieux que
ce soient les noirs qui prenant 1 à 3 et
les blancs gagner du temps sur le
cavalier et le roi est toujours pas
sorti donc la tour est morte donc pas se
presser à faire des échanges qui
favorise l'adversaire vous prend à 3
d'eau topalov tour prend à trois
attaques lecavalier
donc on peut toujours pas à libérer un
roi et tours et le pion ici à 6 va être
en prison voit que le fou aussi attaque
un tacle pions cavale et c5
topalov donc il propose ok si tu fais
fou prend à 6 et bien je peux te plouay
par exemple fou avec la tour et le
cavalier attaque
alors
on a
alors que le régime me signale week on a
des photos du voilà parce que c'est pour
ça que j'étais en train de lire un
message
la régie nous propose des photos du
tie-break de crâne nique aux
championnats du monde qu'on pourra
passer peut-être tout à l'heure dès que
ce sera prêt mais on peut les passer
pendant la partie au ciné sûr si on a
des photos peut-être avant qu'on va
regarder quand même le coup ici de krabi
qui est cavalier b3 elle tombe pas dans
le piège à ne prendre ceux qui ont 6 qui
a empoisonné donc ici il veut échanger
ce cavalier sachant que le pion à 6 ils
veulent prendre chronique
il n'a pas peur de perdre ce pion le
rang qui ont passé un pion passé à ça
peut être très intéressant recettes de
ici de topalov à noter que ce serait
même cadre et ou auto paloffis maginot
que topalov fasse cavalier prend b3 dans
ce cas là on prend du plomb à et tour
prend b3 et tempo site ont pensé 3 est
impossible pourquoi tout simplement à
cause de tour des huit tours des huit
échecs et seront eux c'est très bien on
perd la tour donc ce serait horrible
c'est pas c'est pas gérable donc
cavalli b3 est un gros piège aussi tendu
attendu par kramnik la topaloff
finalement ils t'ont pas dedans topal au
filet pas né de la dernière pluie c'est
quand même pas c'est pas le dernier
joueur du monde
rose cette danse alliés il lisse et tour
en topaloff on a les photos non mais
c'est vrai si on peut les envoyer ça
peut être bien
adacore donc on est en fait les mantras
prix alors d'accord ok alors tour des
4,2 krainik donc là on voit que kramnik
arriva quand même posé d'énormes
problèmes à topalov dans cette dans
cette finale ils menacent cavaliers
prendre cavaliers tourcoing cavaliers
trop profonde g6 donc on enlève le fou
de l'attak et maintenant ces quatre
voilà donc chronique commencent à
avancer son pion ici protéger maintenant
par le fou donc il a plus de problème
avec ce pion qui était inquiété un souci
en c3 donc la position est quand même
équilibré il ya toujours égalité deux
pions ce pion est passé bien sûr mais il
n'est pas facile à valoriser les pour
l'instant bien bien bloqué pour ces six
cavaliers français 5calais prince et 5
et tour prend assise qui gagne
finalement ce pion à 6 et là maintenant
par contre ça devient un vrai souci
alors est-ce que ici dans cette position
topalov aurait pu choisir le coup cavale
et prendre des trains tout simplement
qui aurait quand même eu le désavantage
de lier les pions blancs ici mais après
ils auraient pu protéger ici son pion à
pourquoi pourquoi taux plein ne pas fait
ça alors c'est les parties rapides n'y a
tout simplement pas vu ou estimé que
c'était trop avantageux pour les blancs
peut-être effectivement que les blancs
ici peuvent jouer le coup b4 ensuite
peut-être le coup b5 ça fait quand même
un gros pions passait bien avancé avec
un fou derrière ça devient quand même
difficile alors il a estimé qu' il
pouvait topalov faire après ces quatre
le coutour c6 cavale et prend ses 5 car
les processeurs et tout principe donc
donné ce pion à ça devient quand même
dangereux maintenant pour les noirs
puisque il ya maintenant deux pions
passer ça commence à faire beaucoup
mais bon au final deux tours on peut
toujours tenir alors il ya encore les
foules
donc c'est ça qui fait la différence
tourbes et 8 de topalov il faut
absolument maintenant que topalov arrive
à créer des contrôles menacée surtout
empêcher c'est plus on avance et
idéalement de récupérer un des deux
pions tour des 1/2 kramnik ce pion ici
superbement bien défendus par le four
tour b 2 topalov essaie de créer des
menaces sur la deuxième rangée
donc il va mais on voit que c'est
difficile parce que le fouet fin étant
toujours là on pourra jamais attaqué
jusqu'en j'ai deux formats que le fou
noir arriva à venir sur la case de 4 par
exemple mais c'est pas simple c'est pas
simple échec de
krainik venant sur la septième rangée
roi m6 et maintenant toi hein alors ça
c'est logique on met toujours les tours
derrière les pions passer l'idée tout
simplement c'est de jouer a4 a5 a6 a7 et
a8 dan protégé par la tour très
difficile de parler ce genre de plan
tour f5 logique ce que veut jouer
topalov c'est simplement tout reprend f2
et ensuite floue et 4 et essayer de
créer un des menaces voire même se
contenter d'un échec perpétuelle
maintenant topaloff est en grande
difficulté
il n'a pas choisi il n'a pas choisi la
meilleure solution donnant ce pion à il
a pensé créer des comptes rohm and haas
s'est départi rapide je vous le rappelle
en partie donc il aurait peut-être
choisi un autre choix
topalov mais en tout cas elle était en
difficulté avec ce roi effectivement
qu'ils n'avaient pas ok kramnik a réussi
à les mettre la pression il joué un peu
peut être un peu imprécis cette donnée
ce pion comme ça ce pion à f3 de
cramique alors la très très solide
comment casser ça c'est quasiment pas
possible il va falloir jouer avec les
pions tours 5
maintenant de topalov alors c'est tout
en le 5
bon c'est sûr que le taux f5 que ce
n'était pas bien placé il veut il veut
libérer son fou très certainement mais
cette tour on sait qui est pas super
bien passé non plus tours à 3,2 cramique
alors la lignée de cramique et devenir
tout simplement sur la case d3 et de se
créer un pion passé ici est un pion
passé l'a soutenu tous les deux par deux
tours ce qui serait très fort
voilà l'idée simple de kramnik donc ce
qu'empêche topalov tout de suite je vois
le coutour ces deux voilà il n'empêche
de la tour devenir en c3 et l'a très
bien compris il vaut mieux avoir les
tours qui empêche le pion d'avancé
derrière le pion toujours les pions les
tours derrière les pions en finale
talent cramique va joué superbement
cette finale tour b 3 maintenant on
libère l'avancé de ce pion torah 5
topalov le bloc email à tours pour
bloquer le pion à 4 quand même là on
voit que le pion est bien bloqué par la
tour reut 7 il faut que le roi viennent
participer à la défense
c'est impératif tourbe et celle de crâne
de chroniques ses classiques maintenant
évidemment on peut surtout pas prendre
ici ce serait une erreur énorme puisse
comprendre est tout simplement dû
pioncer et on a deux pions passé lié
c'est énorme on peut plus qu'armé
quasiment plus empêcher ses pions
d'avancé
il sera soutenu par l'audience c'est une
machine infernale avec en plus la tour
quai derrière on peut dire que la partie
est pliée tour b5 donc il faut surtout
pas à échanger les taux et jouer tout à
7 ce qui effectivement le mieux problème
topaloff est vraiment défense et si
kramnik gagne cette partie il va devenir
champion du monde
sans plus de calcul à 5 3 des 6 à 6
évidemment les pions passé sont faits
pour être poussé ses classiques
à noter que topalov a bien fait de
mettre sa tour sur 15 noir puisque
cécile avait bloqué en a6 et aurait eu
des combinaisons avec le fou ici en f1
donc il a bien fait de m
sur la case à 7 est maintenant juste à
temps roi ses sept puisque la menace de
kramix était tour bessette
d'où l'intérêt d'avoir ramener le roi en
défense après droit c'est cette
évidemment tour bessette n'est plus
possible puisque tout simplement il y
aurait prise prises et perte du pion
donc maintenant cramique joue son
deuxième pompe a cessé 5 difficile
difficile pour les noirs de tenir mais
mais ça peut encore tenir ça peut encore
tenir tour ces trois cd partie rapide
tour à à cinq petits coups de cramique
l'idée c'est d'avoir cette tour qui
défend maintenant le pion c'est simple
on va avoir la combinaison que nous
propose g ni tour c'est un essai de
clouer me fous la menace elle est simple
c'est de simplement de jouer fou détroit
est menacée à la fois j'attaque la tour
et je menace pour prend en fout échec et
mat
alors il est celle qui mène donc
attention donc tomber trois logiques de
chroniques qui contrôle la case d3 d'où
l'intérêt d'avoir mis la tour en a cinq
voiliers que le pion ici est toujours
protégé important roy c6 attention
topalov ça y est maintenant il a réussi
son blocage apparemment puisqu'il menace
tout simplement tout reprend ses 5 et 6
les blancs protège le pion c5 et bien
dans ce cas la food & 3 et hop menace
matt attaque la tour on peut dire même
ça gagne la partie
donc il faut faire attention à pas se
tromper sur roy c6 est bien crade igloo
tour s'est super six échecs tout
simplement roi c7 est maintenant il sort
le roi du clonage ou alors web deux
tours ces deux échecs roi de 3 dans
cramique maintenant actifs sont rois
c'est l'heure hélas topalov on peut dire
que topalov craque donc craquage de
topalov enfin 2 en fin de ce championnat
du monde
la partie quand même difficile elle
n'est pas encore perdue c'est quand une
finale de tourments faire maintenant que
le roi blanc quand même avance vers le
centre quand même de plus en plus peur
pour pour topalov mais il a carrément
topalov fait une gaffe in fine aux
gaffes qui donne la partie sur un
plateau et le titre de champion du monde
à kramnik tout reprend ses 5 qui
semblent bons coups puisque si les
blancs jouent tout reprendre tour et
bien tout simplement on prend l'autre
tour et ça y est on a récupéré un pion
et du coup c'est plus la même peut dire
même que la avec le fou ici on va très
certainement arriver à récupérer ce pion
à 6 et on a très bonnes chances de nul
donc ici tour processing et la chronique
à tout lui et il plante tout reprendre
les tours b cet échec
alors voilà toutes les défenses perdent
on peut le voir tout de suite alors la
première descente ce qu'on voit c'est
tombé cet échec on va dire en tout
reprend tour et dans ce cas là on prend
d'abord tout reprend ses 5 avec échec
et si les noirs n'attaque pas la tour en
défense de cet échec
on prendra la deuxième le la tour et on
restera avec une tour de plus donc il
faut défendre les chèques tout en
attaquant la tour mais si on fait roi
des six sur pied reprend tour
effectivement on reprend la tour mais
dans ce cas là les huit dames on veut
dire effectivement que là c'est terminé
il n'ya pas d'autre défense que peuvent
faire les noirs sur cet échec est bien
joué roy c6 par exemple parce que là
c'est perdu aussi puisqu'il y aurait
tout reprendre tour 3 pro tour et tout
simplement pour entoure avec une tour de
plus donc là topaloff
après tout simplement tombé 7 au lieu de
continuer la partie tout simplement
abandonne et donc nous avons là le titre
de champion du monde
2 la dîmière kramnik on peut je crois
qu'on peut voir
je crois une photo où on voit voilà non
est-ce qu'on peut la voir oui voilà donc
on voit ici des photos une photo ici ou
topalov et sur l'échiquier est ici
vladimir kramnik champion du monde
unifié
voilà le match le match et le résultat
qu'on attendait depuis depuis 13 ans on
peut dire que depuis 13 ans n'attendait
qu'un seul champion du monde soit
désigné je crois que là tout le monde
tout le monde maintenant sera d'accord
pour considérer vladimir kramnik
vainqueur de garry kasparov à l'an 2000
qui a gardé son titre face à pete art
déco et qui était en concurrence avec le
champion du monde de feed
alors en l'an 2000 c'était peut-être je
sais plus si c'était kalichman ou si
c'était quasi mise à neuf et ensuite
donc topalov qui était le plus crédible
d'entre tous puisqu'il a gagné son titre
en étant aussi premier sur la liste
mondiale mais il a gagné son titre sur
un tournoi mais la face à cramique en
match et malgré un point acquis par
forfait on peut dire que eh bien ça
n'aura pas suffi on peut dire qu kramnik
a presque gagné deux fois ce match à la
fois dans les parties longues et à la
fois dans le départage il a dû le gagner
deux fois par une manoeuvre aux riches
icje mais là on peut dire que ça y est
le champion du monde unifié des échecs
c'est clair pour tout le monde ces
crânes x et personne d'autre l'intérêt
de ceux de ce titre aussi on peut le
dire c'est que c'est que très
certainement cranie n'acceptera pas de
remettre son titre en jeu dans un
tournoi et que donc on aura droit très
certainement un nouveau match pour la
défense de ce titre alors contre eux qui
s'abaisse à l'avenir nous le dira que
prévoit la fille de maintenant qu'elle a
un champion du monde unifié que peuvent
a déclaré vladimir kramnik et bien tout
ça tout cela fera l'objet des nouvelles
émissions des lônes ltv actualités de
toute cette année vous pouvez évidemment
vous abonner si vous n'êtes pas encore
abonné à les gonades tv on vous invite
évidemment fortement vous abonner c'est
mieux pour nous puisque on perd ça nous
permet de prévoir notre notre production
en fonction du nombre d'abonnés évident
de l'émission s'est lui aussi pour vous
c'est moins cher de s'abonner sur
l'année que d'acheter les émissions à
l'unité merci nous soutenir continuer à
nous écrire sur diagonale tv.com vous
pouvez aussi vous inscrire à la
newsletter l'oublié pas et la prochaine
fois mais nous aurons d'autres invités
évidemment aujourd'hui c'est un jour
spécial où il y avait personne pour ce
championnat du monde malheureusement
pour cette dernière journée
mais nous aurons d'autres d'autres
invités évidemment qui sont prévus dans
l'émission est non seulement des grands
maîtres évidemment mais aussi des gens
qui comptent dans les échecs en france
où des gens aussi en dehors du monde des
échecs comme nous avons l'habitude de le
faire sur des gones à la merci de nous
suivre et à bientôt
oh
m